2018 has been an intense year at the
movies including everything from pulpy
detective fiction
- bloody tales of revenge and all manner
of nervy narratives in-between these are
the most disturbing movies of 2018
many people know Jonathan Ames as a
creative force behind HBO's short-lived
comedy detective series bored to death
but he's also an incisive writer of
genre hopping essays novels and
screenplays verse 2013 novella you are
never really here Ames crafted a
corrosive Leigh bleep piece of detective
fiction about a troubled War vet tasked
with finding the kidnapped
thirteen-year-old daughter of a u.s.
senator indie director and screenplay
writer Lynn Ramsay unleashed the slow
burning beast that was the theatrical
version of you were never really here in
the spring changing very little and
adapting Ames his novel instead Ramsey
bolstered the tightly wound narrative
with stylistic flourishes that ratchet
the tension too near suffocating
extremes the result is a frenzied bloody
deeply paranoid fevered dream of a film
that hammers its way into your head like
a nightmare you won't easily wake from
Hollywood loves a good tale of teenagers
running amok and joining the ranks of
tales of youthful rebellion is Corey
Finley's thoroughbreds as far as tales
of youthful rebellion go Finley sly
bracingly immersive crime drama d is one
for the ages thoroughbreds follows to
upper-class teens who live on opposite
ends of the human emotional spectrum one
incapable of feeling anything while the
other feels everything I don't have any
feelings ever when they're reunited
after years apart each finds themselves
in a position to help the other right of
perceived wrong that help comes at a
high cost for each and together the
teens hatch a violent plan to take
control of the rapidly spiraling lives
the crime itself plays second fiddle to
a focus on the tragically inventive
young minds behind it played by Olivia
Cooke and Anna Taylor joy whose
performances draw you into the comic and
tragic sides of Finley's drama it all
lends an exacting edge to the film's
final moments which may leave you
giggling while also fighting a nasty
chill in your spine core leaf RJ's debut
feature set in the sweltering Moroccan
desert is proof that revenge is not
always a dish best served
old port survival story and part tale of
righteous vengeance revenge unfolds in a
blood-soaked narrative that uses the
desert setting to serve up a steamy
helping a primal payback it begins when
pampered American party girl Jen's get
away with Richard is interrupted after
his pals show up early for a hunting
trip the weekend pivots dramatically
after a deplorable act that leads
Richard to leave Jen for dead in the
unforgiving desert she awakes to find
herself in the midst of a deadly cat and
mouse chase transformed from object to
Avenger leading to one of the best
hunters become the hunted narratives in
recent memory it's brutal bloody and
inventive in ways we can't go into
without spoiling the fun just know that
the almost dialogue free action is
guided to a final showdown that will
leave you absolutely shaken to the core
every so often we get a scary movie that
transcends its genre roots this year
that movie is unquestionably re Astor's
utterly terrifying family drama
hereditary the less you know going in
the better but we can't say that this
film begins dark and aster spends the
next hour tightening the screws to an
unbearable sense of atmospheric dread
before hitting you with one of the most
shocking moments and horror movie
history you'll never see it coming it'll
shock you in ways you've probably never
experienced in a movie and as impossible
as it may seem when it happens
hereditary then sets about getting a
whole lot darker if you're tough enough
to stick with it you'll be able to brag
to friends that you made it through one
of the best most disturbing horror films
not just the 2018 but likely of all time
unfolding and a beautifully realised
alternate version of present-day
Oakland sorry to bother you follows the
story of a young black telemarketer who
experiences a meteoric rise to success
after uncovering his inner white voice
as always we'll be getting that out to
you right away what follows is a
hilarious often horrifying madcap farce
that plays like a mash-up of Being John
Malkovich and get out
only angrier and more perceptive sorry
to bother you maybe chocked full of
comically inspired moments but it's
absolutely venomous in its presentation
of gender and race relations and
economic structures and it never misses
a beat as it pivots effortlessly from
one shocking moment to the next director
boots Riley's cast doesn't
Abid either and they keep Riley's
politically charged sci-fi Fantasia
grounded in particularly hard-hitting
ways though it may leave you wincing the
next time you see a horse man Luca
Guadagnino Suspiria is a fresh ferocious
and surprisingly political take on Dario
Argento's bloody brooding 1977 horror
classic the newest version of the
twisted tale about an enigmatic dancer
being tormented by Dark Horse's
actually best the film that inspired it
in both scope and scares Suspiria s--
2018 version also dances past Argento's
original and runtime clocking in at a
hefty 152 minutes and is filled with
welcome narrative additions like
character development and actual dancing
it also tends to avoid blind bloodlust
in favor of mood and Menace as well
ratcheting up the tension with fiery
flourishes of nightmarish imagery that
punctuate the gruesome acts of violence
throughout even if you've seen Argento
Suspiria you won't be prepared for the
gritty grisly carnage Guadagnino brings
to the table making his take not just
one of the most ambitious ly unsettling
remakes ever produced but also one of
the best Mandy is a film whose atypical
revenge narrative certainly fits the
b-movie mold even as it mercilessly
transcends expectations made even better
by the fact that Nicolas Cage plays a
man hell-bent on avenging the murder of
his lover somehow Mandy ended up being
one of the most memorable films and
cages filmography
it's crazy evil is what director Panos
cosmatos does with this construct that
makes the film so uniquely disquieting
peppering the action with a murderous
cult of hippies led by a folk singing
wannabe demigod throw in a demonic biker
gang hallucinatory narcotics
surrealistic imagery and enough fake
blood to float an ark and you've earned
a spot in the vaunted cult classic canon
yes Mandy is every bit the b-movie it
seems but it's also one of the most
visually striking vividly realized and
wholly original films of the year and
it's unbridled insanity simply must be
seen to be believed
caged crazier than usual crazier than
this
[Music]
[Applause]
now that st. something.when author Jeff
Vandermeer published anihilation it
became an instant classic of modern
science fiction literature and an easy
target for a big screen adaptation fans
of the book were even more excited when
hearing that Alex Garland was handling
that adaptation after months of delays
and behind-the-scenes troubles
annihilation finally arrived in theaters
except it didn't exactly stick to the
source material garland took some
serious liberties with the story to
cramp the narrative all his own but his
annihilation works as both a direct
adaptation and a wholly original story
that's every bit as effective horrifying
and emotionally charged as the book
garland even best Van der Meers source
material when it comes to scares with a
blood-curdling bear woman beast that
serves as one of the most unsettling
creature creations of this or any year
if only garland had left the door open
for a sequel we might have gotten to see
even more his haunting unearthly
delights with no fewer than a couple
dozen or so films utilizing social
medias like share obsession as a plot
device
Robert McClure sobering drama like me is
nothing like the rest
in fact this incisive feature debut is
not like any film you've ever seen
before from its jarring opening moments
mock lers film is clearly out to shock
his tragic tale of a young woman
broadcasting her crime spree across
social media is part road movie part
hallucinatory crime thriller opening
with an attention-grabbing heist and
ending with brutal violence the moments
in between find a hushed and harried
character study vivid photography and
kaleidoscopic editing ensure that even
the film's muted moments come and go
with galvanizing energy that manic mix
of styles makes like me the sort of
soul-crushing spirited film you simply
cannot unsee so make sure that you do
after unleashing his sweaty palm action
epic the raid in 2011 and following it
up with the equally bonkers the raid -
Gareth Evans proved himself to be a
master of both staging and human drama
so there was good reason to be excited
when Netflix announced they'd be
producing Evans's new film apostle which
saw the director tackling the horror
genre the result was a
riah thriller about a troubled man
tasked with retrieving his sister from a
creepy island dwelling religious cult
who worship a bloodthirsty deity for the
first hour the movie swings a
hypnotically unholy pendulum before
viewers eyes giving apostle linear
suffocating gothic energy and then evan
spends the next hour smashing that
pendulum into bloody bits making you
long for time when a bloodthirsty deity
was all you had to fear expect dastardly
deeds unspeakably gruesome acts
fantastically grotesque imagery and a
soul choking sense of dread
you'll be glued to the screen for every
nightmarish moment we're in a virtual
Golden Age of genre mashups and one
amazing example of this is that
gloriously unhinged World War 2 horror
thriller Overlord few other 2018 films
arrive as well-equipped to delight and
disturb an equal measure odds are you've
heard overlord categorized as a nazi
zombie horror flick which is only a
little bit misleading yes there are lots
of evil Nazis and the dead aren't always
exactly dead but we can tell you there's
a lot more going on here than meets the
eye the film set on the eve of d-day is
an excellent World War two movie opening
with a harrowing parachute drop behind
enemy lines following a band of soldiers
on a suicide mission that will turn the
tide of the war that mission leads them
to a french village teeming with nazi
soldiers and scientists without spoiling
the film just know that the
stomach-churning things uncovered in
there is the stuff of nightmares
Overlord is the action-packed
blood-soaked war horror hybrid we never
knew we needed after bursting into
Hollywood is described behind the
legendary film taxi driver Paul Schrader
has continued to make a name for himself
as a screenwriter of unyielding vision
and some very specific opinions about
the world at large
Schrader was also directed his share of
classics with titles like American
Gigolo affliction and auto focus he
returned to the director's chair this
year to unleash first reform reminding
us he still got plenty to say about the
state of society traders latest is a
politically charged narrative of
societal despair environmental calamity
and righteous indignation it pits a
well-intentioned priest against the
world where moral duplicity has led to
big business corrupting not just society
but also the environment and the church
anchored by a career-best performance
from ethan hawke first reformed is a
desolate piece of work
driven by insightful writing
unforgettable imagery and an atmospheric
energy that teeters ever on the edge of
horror it's also a bone-chilling call to
arms that we can only hope has not come
too late check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about messed up movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you